let's continue our tour of different
races across the country some of them
scarier than others today we're going to
look at california republican secretary
of state candidate rachel hamm who
uh has decided to run for office
because her son found jesus inside a
closet in her house
this is really wacky stuff and we are
going to look at a couple of clips of
her here is rachel hamm again candidate
for secretary of state in california
she's a republican talking to us about
how she is trying to use prayer
to steal votes back so this this is very
convoluted
she believes democrats are stealing
votes
and she's going to pray
for god to send angels to steal the
votes back now why wouldn't god just
prevent the vote theft to begin with
we'll never know but take a listen to
this i would pray that i win
yep one thing that i've been doing is
praying that if anyone tries to steal a
vote that god would send the angels to
steal the vote back to make it an honest
vote yeah i think we might as well ask i
mean angels are you know they can do
things they can do jobs so i think we
should get a lot of them are actually in
unions they prefer union work a job with
the election help us make it an honest
one so angels if there are any fake
ballots that have been produced burn
them up find him and destroy him if
votes are flipped in the machines
left away from the candidate someone
voted for flip it back and i don't care
which way if it's from me to someone
else because that's what's honest just
make it an honest vote right so i'm not
asking for cheating i'm not asking the
angels to cheat i'm asking the angels to
prevent cheating right now with all of
these things i always kind of apply kind
of like an occam's razor thing which is
first of all if there is a god is god
really concerned with the election of
the california secretary of state or
would god be more worried about bigger
issues and then they can come back and
say well god is all-powerful and god is
all-knowing so god is involved in
everything god's involved in uh does
that banana
that you ate uh does did it does it have
food poisoning are you gonna get sick
from the banana or is it good god's
involved in everything okay well so why
is she even running um she explained
that she's running because of something
about jesus being in her closet
what what was the the
reason behind deciding to run for this
office i mean you've got a lot of things
first of all i'm a prophetic dreamer so
i had spent a lot of 2019 and 20 having
a lot of political dreams that i was in
office right and because our youngest
son ezekiel is a seer i went and got him
and i said hey can you look around and
see what you're seeing because and and
now there's a real question as to
whether
her son
through heredity became a seer or
whether it's something he learned
i i just really i get a kick out of
hearing him describe you know what he
sees and so i said you know let me know
if you see anything and so he looked in
my bedroom and my bathroom he said
there's nothing there and then he goes
into the closet which is where i had
been when i was praying right and he
said whoa and his eyes got like biggest
saucers and he kind of like started
backing away and they started bending
down and he said you've got a really big
guy in your closet and his power is
pushing me to the ground and he had
never had he'd never had that reaction
ever
to an angel and so i'm like is he he's
he's for us not against us right because
it's a different response and he's like
he's full of lie he's so full of light i
can't even see his face
and and then he said and he has a scroll
in his hand
and so i was like then he came with a
message what is the message
and the message was a commissioning so
at the very end i asked him what his
name was because i thought
what angel is this you know and he said
emmanuel
right that wasn't an angel
i wasn't an angel that was jesus himself
there you go so
that's why i'm running for secretary of
state yeah it's kind of a she the kid
also found an angel in her washing
machine and then it turned out it was
actually um it was actually fabric
softener
uh so what do we do about that what how
what what i mean i guess hopefully she
loses we'll know that it was legit
because at this point god and jesus and
angels are so involved that if they
can't get her over the finish line
nothing can but
this is uh unfortunately this is very
common in the united states and i know
it's really scary for a lot of our
viewers around the world and for
children to hear this stuff because it
is pretty freaky
but um
that's a candidate that's a candidate
folks
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video